[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde Afrique France faut-il évacuer
nos bases militaires en Afrique beaucoup
de pays africains qui aujourd'hui
cultivent un sentiment anti-français se
sont éloignés de l'ancien pays
colonisateur comme on dit à travers un
PCH militaire c'est notamment le cas du
Mali du BurkinaFaso du Niger le cas du
Gabon est un peu spécial parce qu'il
s'est il a changé de régime par la voie
pchiste pardon mais sans sentiments ou
sans vindidictes anti-français les pches
en Afrique sont d'une banalité
reproductive il y en eu plus de 200
depuis les indépendances africaines
intervenu dans les années 60 reste cette
énigme ou plutôt ce retournement de
paradigme qui voit se substituer à la
définte France-Afrique une antifrance
populiste pleine de ressentiments
vis-à-vis de l'ancien pays colonisateur
et cherchant à se débarrasser de toute
présence militaire tricolore pourtant
appelé à la rescousse pour combattre le
terrorisme djihadiste d'où vient et
pourquoi cette attitude anti-française
qui peut faire tache d'huile et
contagion dans les pays africains
abritant encore des bases militaires
françaises à savoir la Côte d'Ivoire le
Sénégal le Gabon Djibouti le Tchad d'où
notre question du jour faut-il évacuer
ces bases militaires au-delà du
ressentiment nous chercherons à évoquer
avec les questions stratégiques
n'oublions pas que l'Afrique est un
carrefour convoité par de nombreux pays
et de nombreuses puissances émergentes
évoquer le contexte
géo-économique lié à une mondialisation
créant de nouveaux rapports de
dépendance et de prédation est-ce que
l'Afrique dispose aujourd'hui des moyens
pour assurer ça c'est urité et aussi de
s'interroger sur une diplomatie
française qui de la Libye au Maghreb
s'avère ératique et bien souvent
infructueuse avec ou sans base militaire
pour en parler je vous présente mes
invités Antoine Glazer vous êtes
journaliste essayiste et vous consacrz à
l'Afrique depuis longtemps niagalé
Bagayoko vous êtes politologue vous
enseignez à Science Po et vous avez
également une fondation je crois
l'African Security Network alors nous av
nos autres invités sont en
visioonférence alors je présenterai le
général Bruno Clément bolet bonjour
général vous êtes ex-decteur de la
coopération de sécurité et de défense au
kéorsé Aminata Draman Traoré nous vous
avons j'allais dire en visio mais en
vérité par téléphone vous êtes une femme
politique et écrivaine malienne et le
colonel Roger cuitchet colonel de
réserve dans l'armée camerounaise et
nous vous avons en vision depuis
[Musique]
Yaoundé alors j'allais dire question
d'ambiance Antoine Glazer est-ce qu'on
peut dire au qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui de l'implantation et du
développement du terrorisme en Afrique
alors je sais pas ce qu'on peut dire du
terrorisme en Afrique à l'évidence même
les bases militaires françaises ou la
présence militaire française il faut
quand même se rappeler que la France est
la seule puissance extérieure au
continent à avoir des bases permanentes
encore en Afrique à l'exception de
Djibouti où là il y a le monde entier
chinois
américains tourn vers l'Indo-Pacifique
mais en ce qui concerne le continent
africain c'est vrai que la France est la
seule puissance à avoir encore des bases
permanentes et c'est vrai que la les
Africains reprochent à la France de pas
avoir soldé cette période post-coloniale
des indépendances de 1960 jusqu'à le la
fin de 1989 90 la la la fin de l'Union
soviétique de l'empire soviétique sur ce
continent comme la France n'a pas soldé
finalement cette présence de l'armée
française a servi finalement de cache
misère à une présence française qui
était glob globalement en désérrance ça
veut dire ces militaires ces bases
militaires ont laissait croire que la
France était encore chez elle en Afrique
que c'était encore elle qui drivait le
continent alors que l'Afrique est
totalement mondialisée et donc je pense
que là il y a une espèce de yatus et
c'est vrai que les bases la question du
maintien des bases pose la question des
relations entre la France et l'Afrique
puisque ces militaires étaient hors sol
par rapport aux réalités du terrain
alors écoutez donc sur cette question
question du terrorisme madame niagal
Bakayoko quelle est votre perception de
ce qu'il en est du terrorisme en Afrique
on parlera des autres sujets après mais
sur le terrorisme alors tout
d'abord il faut s'interroger sur ce que
l'on place sous ce vocable de terrorisme
puisqu'il ne faut pas oublier que on a
affaire à des mouvances extrêmement
diversifié qui ont eu tendance à à être
trop souvent réduite les unes aux autres
alors qu'il y a des affrontements entre
elles c'est très important de mettre cet
élément en avant notamment si l'on prend
le cas du Sahel vous avez une opposition
entre les groupes affiliés à l'état
islamique et les groupes affiliés à
Al-Qaïda qui se combattent les uns et
les autres cette variable est
fondamentale mais par ailleurs on
s'aperçoit qu'on a beaucoup trop réduit
à cette lutte contre ces groupes armés
terroristes dit Gat les
euh difficultés sécuritaire expérimenté
par le continent alors que l'on assiste
également à l'émergence de Milic
d'autodéfense de groupes communautarisés
qui s'affrontent de rébellions
politico-militaires certaines
indépendantiste d'autres nom au regain
bien sûr du prétorianisme sur le
continent donc c'est cet ensemble
d'éléments qu'il faut prendre en
considération pour lutter contre ces
insurrections qui ont une composante
djihadiste mais dont certains groupes se
présentent au contraire comme combattant
avant tout les états jugés corrompus et
partenaires de l'Occident et se pose en
protecteur des populations donc la
problématique n'est pas aussi simple on
voit très bien que cette guerre contre
le terrorisme a été perdue absolument
par qu'il s'agisse de l'Afghanistan
qu'il s'agisse du Moyen-Orient elle a
également été perdue au Sahel parce qu'à
mon avis ce vocable est beaucoup trop
simpliste on vous a entendu là-dessus
alors colonel Roger quitch quelle est
votre analyse de la présence et de la
prégnance du terrorisme aujourd'hui dans
le continent africain plus spécialement
peut-être dans le
Sahel juste une précision avant de
répondre à votre question je ne suis pas
colonel à la réserve mais à la retraite
j'ai épuisé ma période de réserve don
don je suis actuellement dégagé de
toutes les obligations militaires je
suis à la retraite bon alors ceci dit
poser le problème du terrorisme en
Afrique dans le cadre de cette émission
dans le titre dans l'objet phare c'est
les bases africaines en Afrique c'est
vouloir peut-être lier les bases de la
présence des bases humitaires françaises
en Afrique au terrorisme contre le
terrorises sont là pour ça ben elles
sont là pour ça mais d'où vient le
terrorisme s'il faut reculer dans le
temps jusqu'au moi si fa parler p comme
le père bal branche jusqu'au premier
hini le terrorisme il est arrivé quand
en Afrique qu'est-ce qui se passait
avant mais les troues françaises les
troupes françaises étaient en Afrique
longtemps avant l'arrivée du du
terrorisme alors si s étaient là avant
l'arrivée du terrorisme
ell y étit pourquoi donc le terrorisme
en Afrique aujourd'hui il pour ven troit
à votre question il est prignant mais
depuis quelques temps je crois que les
États africains se donnent les moyens de
faire face
à cette pandémie à cette
hdre l'Afrique aujourd'hui a juste
besoin de pas grand-chose pour venir à
bout du terrorisme partout où il se
trouve c'est ce que nous pensons mais
est-ce que vous pensez que le terrorisme
est contagieux jusqu'à l'intérieur des
états la cont faudit savoir que le
terrorisme est au départ une
doctrine
c'est au départ une doctrine et qu'on ne
tue pas une doctrine c'est des idées qui
circulent des idées qui circulent
pourquoi sur la base de certaines
revendications faites aux autorités et
qui entraînent parfois la radicalisation
de certaines parties parties
prenante ce n'est que des individus qui
peuvent diffuser le leurs idées à
travers les frontières pour que le
terrorisme mais n'oubliez pas que le
terrorisme
originel n'existe pratique pas pas qui
n'existe pas mais les bandits de grands
chemins prennent pour manteau le
terrorisme pour agir oui les idées
peuvent circuler d'un pays à l'autre
mais l'impact et la signification tant
que les idées diadistes et autres ne
sont pas assimilés vont connaître des
limites oui alors le général Clément
bolet on vous on vous retrouve là quel
est-ce que les bases militaires
françaises anciennes et présentes
était là et sont là pour lutter contre
le terrorisme puisque nous sommes là à
ce niveau de la conversation
oui alors peut-être un petit mot juste
pour revenir sur le le terme de
terrorisme parce qu'on le dévoie
beaucoup en ce moment un petit peu
partout cont tenu l'amplaire de de des
événements qui sont liés le terrorisme
je rappelle que c'est un mode d'action
hein c'est un mode d'action euh le
terrorisme dont nous parlons en Afrique
actuellement c'est ce sont des des des
religieux extrémistes qui ont pris comme
mode d'action pour faire valoir leur
extrémisme euh le le principe du
terrorisme terrorisme donc inspiré la
terreur auprès des populations
euh les bases françaises en Afrique
actuellement il y a 6000 militaires
français en Afrique réparti sur quatre
bases c'est les bases qu'on connaissait
hier et qui ont été revisité un petit
peu et très fortement dégraissés enfin
les effectifs ont été très fortement
diminués ces dernières années il nous
reste donc le le Sénégal
la Côte d'Ivoire le Gabon et Djibouti ce
total fait à peu près 3000 3000 soldats
et et il faut ajouter à ça les éléments
français du Sahel donc qui sont répartis
entre Niger de moins en moins et le
Tchad qui sont à peu près 2500 à ça il
faudrait rajouter la petite mission
CORIM de de la mission maritime qui est
dans le Golf de Guinée avec 500
personnes à peu près et puis en fond de
tableau on a aussi le dispositif de
coopération militaire qui n'est pas très
important quantitativement mais qui
qualitativement de par la position qu'
et coopérant dans les systèmes
sécuritaires en Afrique représente un
dispositif qu'il ne faut pas négliger
voilà et donc c'est ces bases françaises
si vous voulez le le particip-elle au au
terrorisme oui dans la mesure où elle
coopère avec les états dans lesquels
elles sont installées et donc par ce
bienia là elle coopère mais ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui de la coopération du type de
celle qu'on a vécu au travers de de
barcan mais peut-être un mot sur à quoi
servent-ell ces ces ces ces bases
française pour on va y venir général on
va y venir alors je voudrais avoir
l'avis de Madame Aminata trauré
là-dessus vous sur la persistance du
terrorisme en Afrique à quoi vous
l'attribuez je rappelle que vous a par
téléphone oui je je je commencer par
dire que c'est un mot
impasse
Fourtout le débat fait rage à ce sujet
en ce moment en France à la faveur du
conflit
israëlo-palestinien je crois que la même
perspicacité
devrait s'imposer dans l'analyse de ce
dont il s'agit et en Afrique parce que
moi ce que je sais si je me réfère aux
réalité de mon pays le Mali en son nom
la France est revenue avec arme et
bagage à imposé son
narratif sa stratégie
elle a échoué c'est ce qui a amené le
peuple malien qui avait accueilli
l'opération servval avec enthousiasme à
demandé le départ et de barcane et de
l'aminissement donc cela doit être clair
et il y avait pas dès les années 60 le
président miib Keita a demandé le départ
de de de l'armée française le dernier
soldat français parti et la réalité du
Mali les autres pays qui sont
aujourd'hui qui abritent des bases
militaires c'est pas le cas du Mali donc
l'intervention militaire de la France au
Mali au nom d' d'un phénomène qu'on
appelle le terrorisme et dans
et lui a valu ce que vous appelez
sentiment anti-fançais c'est pas lié eu
au coup d'État et c'était et c'est
antérieur c'est lié d'abord à l'échec de
C ce type d'intervention militaire dans
le cadre de la lutte contre un phénomène
qu'on appelle le terrorisme islamiste
oui mais madame Traoré madame Traoré je
voudrais quand même qu'on éclaircisse
quelque chose vous avez évoqué le
Moyen-Orient la position française c'est
que le Hamas est un groupe terroriste et
en même temps il y a un soutien pour la
création de deux états et au peuple
palestinien est-ce que vous considérer
qu'en Afrique le califat et tout ce qui
est venu comme terrorisme après la
j'allais dire la disparition de Kaddafi
a amené en Afrique un terrorisme de
nature
islamiste d'abord il y a pas de khalifat
il y avait un khalifat
avant je vous
cite le notre ministre le cor nuU a
déclaré que la recrudescence du
terrorisme nous laisse craindre que
l'implantation d'un califat que nous
avons réussi à entraver et repousser
vous êtes pas d'accord avec cette
opinion c'est la position française mais
c'est absolument faux c'est le narratif
français qui permet qui a permis de de
de de fédérer les opinions de de à à son
intervention moi je voudrais que 10 ans
plus tard vraiment qu'on se rende à
l'évidence si vous voulez éviter comme
vous l'avez dit en introdu et
l'exempension à l'échelle du continent
du sentiment antifrançais il faut
vraiment sortir il faut sortir de
l'inaudibilité qui caractérise la France
qui est le manque total d'objectivité
qui on on ne nous écoute pas on nous
éoutoute pas vous êtes dans
l'interprétation mais je vous dis ce que
je je je regrette je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ce diagnostique de
Monsieur le Cornu nous sommes dans une
impasse lié au fait que les solutions ne
sont pas en face de mot dont souffre
l'Afrique merci euh Antoine Glazer sur
ce point-là parce que il semblerait
qu'il y ait pas d'accord sur non mais je
dire il fallait à un certain moment
donné que la France justifie sa présence
militaire vis-à-vis finalement des
citoyens français en disant attention le
terrorisme va venir de cette zone
sahéo-saharienne c'est complètement faux
on n jamais vu un Malien faire un acte
terroriste en France ça a toujours été
beaucoup plus nos banlieux alors qu'il
ait un certain nombre de de de de
citoyens français qui sont allés au
proche Moyen-Orient ça c'est une autre
histoire mais il y a un amalgame
absolument incroyable dans toute cette
zone saau saharienne entre ce qui est ce
qui a été dits par le général Bruno
clémmentbolet entre les coupeurs de
route où les gens les trafiquent en tout
genre cette zone c'est une très grande
zone de trafic en tout genre que ça soit
la drogue le trafic humain et cetera un
certain nombre de jeunes bien sûr ont
été pris en main par des groupes
islamistes mais pouvait-ce que il
cherchait simplement du travail donc ça
s'il y a pas de califat ni quoi que ce
soit et puis il y a une chose dont
personne ne parle c'est que c'est une
période historique qui oui mais
l'intervention de la France à l'époque
de la présidence Hollande au Mali c'est
faite pour combattre le terrorisme c'est
pour empêcher un petit groupe c'est pour
empêcher un certain nombre effectivement
de djihadistes d'ailleurs donù la France
avait une responsabilité avec
l'assassinat du colonel Kaddafi qui sont
rentrés de Libye des des toire qui
effectivement étaient des
indépendantistes qui se sont alliés avec
des gens de alkaïa du Maghreb islamique
ce qui a donné le groupe de soutien
l'islam et aux musulmans mais c'était un
petit groupe si la France il serait
descendu il serait pas arrivé à bamaco
s'était arrêté la France servale serait
parti il y aurait eu aucun problème mais
quand on les gens ne connaissent pas ils
se rendent pas compte que il y a une
islamisation faut pas confondre le
terrorisme avec l'islamisation de cette
zone depuis la Mauritanie jusqu'au
Soudan mais avec des W V avec des gens
avec du prosolitisme saoudien qatari des
émiratis ça veut dire et sans
imprégnation terroriste mais mais il y a
une bien sûr qu'il y a des noyaux
terroristes mais c'est pas l'essentiel
c'est le retour c'est une la période
postcoloniale on rentre dans une
nouvelle période historique avec c'est
l'Afrique des africains mais mais il y a
une diversité même entre eux et je veux
dire c'est vrai que tu tu tu as raison
quand tu dis que par exemple al de
Maghreb islamique ils se battent avec
l'État islamique au Grand Sahara il y a
aussi un certain nombre de de de il se
combattent entre eux donc c'est c'est
une situation qui est très complexe et
il faut comprendre que c'est une période
historique est en train de changer
écoutez général Clément bolet vous
comment vous défendez alors dans ce
cas-là les interventions françaises si
elles n'étit pas là pour lutter contre
un le
terrorisme alors peut-être on risque de
vous de vous surprendre je crois que au
départ de cette de cette affaire donc
2012 2013 il me semble euh pour ma part
que il y a il y a peut-être une erreur
d'analyse et qu'on a confondu les causes
et les conséquences euh globalement je
suis parfaitement en phase avec ce que
vient de dire Antoine Glazer euh j'ai
peur que on est fait du terrorisme qui
commençait à descendre vers bamaco
l'unique cause de la déstabilisation de
toute cette régionl euh mais je pense
que ça n'était pas la cause ça n'était
qu'une conséquence la conséquence de
tout ce que vient d'expliquer Antoine
Glazer d'une zone complètement laissée à
l'abandon une absence d'État quasi
totale où l'État ne remplit plus ses
missions régaliennes de d'éducation des
des des des jeunes de santé des
populations de résolution des problèmes
sociaux et donc dans ce magma et dans
cette anarchie global et ben le le
terrorisme qui descendait avait beau jeu
de faire son lit et euh et j'ai peur que
l'analyse qu'on en a faite se soit
concentrée quasi uniquement sur cette
affaire de terrorisme oubliant le reste
et donc la réponse que nous avons donné
pendant des années jusqu'à 2021 2022 n'a
été quasiment que sécuritaire au
détriment d'une vision globale qui nous
aurait permis d'apporter des réponses
outre sécuritaires mais des réponsse
politique économique sociale et c'est
tout ça qui a manqué et je je crois que
euh je met pas du tout en faute euh les
militaires qui ont à mon sens très bien
fait techniquement ce qu'on leur
demandait euh je remets en cause
l'analyse au départ de notre engagement
qui a fait que euh on a fait du du
problème sécuritaire en du problème du
terrorisme l'unique cause de ce qu'il
fallait descendre et donc quand vous
avez qu'une cause vous donnez des
réponsse à la cause et donc la seule
réponse que nous avons donnée puisque
notre analyse était très courte elle a
été sécuritaire alors niagalé Bakayoko
sur ce point-là alors ce que je trouve
très intéressant dans cette discussion
c'est que nous sommes quand même cinq
intervenants qui ont une convergence
absolue dans leurs analyses c'est-à-dire
que on ne niit pas qu'il y a des actes
de nature terroriste dans cette zone
bien entendu mais d'abord les actes qui
sont commis n'ont rien à voir avec le
terrorisme tel qu'on a pu l'expérimenté
en Europe il y a eu très peu d'attentats
ciblant des civils dans les villes
notamment ce sont sont plutôt les
populations qui sont les premières
victimes de ces différents groupes
djihadistes c'est la première chose on
ne va pas nier non plus que l'emprise de
ces insurrections djihadistes s'étend
maintenant au-delà du Sahel pour toucher
notamment les pays côtiers voir
certaines zones de l'Afrique centrale et
de l'Est ce que l'on soulligne tous je
pense c'est que on ne peut pas
considérer que le mot de terrorisme
suffit à résumer la réalité sécuritaire
de cette zone ça c'est le premier
élément et d'autre part la présence
militaire française est bien antérieure
comme l'a dit le colonel tout à l'heure
à cette problématique dite terroriste et
a donc d'autres d'autres explications la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui est de
savoir pourquoi il y a un tel rejet de
la France c'est notamment parce que la
France a affirmé être en mesure
d'éradiquer le terrorisme alors que la
crise sécuritaire est beaucoup plus
large et excède bien entendu non
seulement les moyens de la France mais
ceux de tous les partenaires
internationaux on voit l'échec des
nations- Unies on voit l'échec de
l'Union européenne on voit l'échec
également de la Russie sur le plan
sécuritaire qui n'inverse pas la
situation parce que une fois de plus les
manifestations sont beaucoup beaucoup
plus larges et je pense qu'il est
important que nos dirigeants aussi le
prennent en considération parce que euh
l'insécurité ne cesse de progresser mais
les réponses trop militarisées notamment
ne permettent pas d'y répondre madame
aminaat troré vous voulez intervenir je
rappelle que vous êtes en liaison radio
oui oui je je crois que il faut en finir
également avec euh cette idée selon
laquelle euh la zo est laissé à
l'abandon par des états faibles faillis
ainsi de suite et c'est totalement
insuffisant pour rendre compte des
causes structurelles et de du phénomène
dont il s'agit et pour rendre compte et
des des de de la lame de fond qui fait
que et le ce dont il
s'agitaelon le terrorisme pour l'instant
se répend on donne l'impression en ce
moment aux États côtiers et au reste de
l'Afrique que circonscrire le mal au
Sahel les mettra à l'abri justement de
tout ce que nous déplorons aujourd'hui
il s'agit pas de de de de de l'abandon
de l' il ne s'agit pas que de
l'incapacité de ces états ce sont des
état si si nous nous nous nous occultons
le contexte dans lequel ce phénomène a
surgi et parallèlement au phénomène
migratoire je parle la migration comme
elle se déroule en ce moment c'est lié à
à l'échec lamentable du modèle
économique mise en œuvre dans ces pays
les programmes d'ajustement structurel
qui ne permettent pas qui n'ont pas
permis et tout ce qui qu'on comp qu'
tout ce qui se poursuit en ce moment qui
ne permet pas de créer d'emplois de
répondre aux besoins existentiel des
gens et pousseent les poussent dans les
bras de ce que vous voulez toutes sortes
de trafiquants dont les les ceux qui
recrutent ces jeuneslà et pour en faire
des combattants d'une cause qui que
eux-mêmes ne définissent mal donc il y a
énormément de de malentendu autour de
cette affaire là tant qu'on aura pas
compris justement à la faveur du
basculement du monde qui est en cours
que la France a cruellement besoin de
l'Afrique qui s'agit pas du sauvetage du
Mali du Burkina du reste du du continent
il s'agit du sauvetage du de de la
France elle-même merci Madame merci
madame je vais demander l'avis du
colonel Roger cuitchet là-dessus et vous
me dites colonel dans ce cas-là pourquoi
avoir fait venir la milice Wagner si ça
n'est pas pour lutter contre du
terrorisme alors je madame je vis
j'avais d'abord voulu rebondir sur
l'inaudibilité dont a parlé madame je
crois c'est Madame Aminata je pense que
ce genre ce type d'émission permet de
tirer des leçons pour améliorer l'avenir
et cette
inudibilité est un véritable
problème comment ne peut-on pas se
rendre compte qu'en Afrique aujourd'hui
euh on assiste à au déploement des des
dynamismes plus ou moins
affirmés tendant à la liquidation de de
des systèmes coloniaux de
prédation les rébellions idéologiques et
parfois militaire le montre à suffisance
ne pas le voir si s'posit encore aux
surprises
stratégique
mais les les bases militaires j'ai
essayé de parcourir un peu les les les
missions des militaires
en
Afrique la mission c'est
protéger les les ressentissants Français
sur le territoire africains et protéger
les intérêts français cuit des intérêts
du pays
Hute ça c'est dans tous les dans tous
les pays que ce soit les éléments
français ou Tchad les éléments
licorne l'opération Licorne qu'est-ce
qu'ils font en Afrique après tous ces
événements donc le véritable problème
vient de ce que il n pas j'allais dire
une sorte deud pour comprendre
exactement quels sont les besoins de
l'Afrique on les problèmes de l'Afrique
des missions militaire anormalement
longue sans objectifs précis déterminés
dans le temps et mesur des objectifs
mesurables dans le
temps alors ben si vous posez la
question de savoir pourquoi Warner est
là avant Warner l'Afrique existait
l'Afrique se
battait aujourd'hui si la France ne veut
pas se rendre compte de la nécessité de
la multip polarité et d'essayer de se
battre se conformer aux réalités au
monde qui change pour accepter la
multipolarité et tous les autres
partenaires qui sont là ce serait
vraiment difficile pour tout le monde
tout le monde a besoin de tout le monde
pour se bâtir
oui donc pour pour venir là-dessus j'ai
dis les missions françaisees en Afrique
elles sont arrivé on les a bien ACC mais
elles sont elles sont anormalement
longues elles n'ont pas d'agenda bien
défin j'ai regardé tout à l'heure il y a
environ
5630 militaires français en Afrique mais
c'est pourquoi pendant ce temp la France
colonel colonel permettez que je vous
interrompe si on regarde les échanges
économiques entre l'Afrique et le reste
du monde la France est très loin
derrière des pays comme la Chine donc en
matière de prédation la France est donc
très très loin de cette prédation qui
peut venir de l'Asie la question que je
vous pose c'est que est-ce que la les
forces qui viennent de Chine de Turquie
de Russie vous pensez qu'elles sont là
uniquement par
philanthropie personne n'est dupe vous
pensez qu'il y a de la philanthropie les
États n'ont pas d'amis les États n'ont
que des intérêts si la France est restée
longtemps en Afrique c'est parce qu'il
avait vu son intérêt mais le véritable
problème ce que nous constatons
aujourd'hui avec le recul que la France
a très peu pris en compte les intérêts
des Africains la France a été inudible
par rapport au point je viens de lire là
qu'on a qu'on a publié un rapport je
vous en prie qu'on a publié un rapport
de l'Assemblée nationale sur la raison
du sentiment anti-français moi je ne
DIRIS pas sentiment antifrançais la
relation avec la France c'est un
héritage qu'on assume nous parlons le
français moi je dirais un sentiment anti
poliitique française nous aimons bien la
France nous parlons le français nous
avons beaucoup d'amis en France donc
c'est pas un sentiment français en tant
que tel ben dans ce
rapport il me paraît qu'on dit qu'il
faut rebâtir les relations avec la
France à travers une aide au
développement réorienté
et une une efficacité de l'aide publique
au développement et une offre
stratégique et militaire c'est ce que
nous attendons depuis 60 ans très peu
d'armées africaines qui ont évolué avec
la France dispose de matériel français
pour faire face au adisme colonel
colonel le général Clément baolet veut
réagir là-dessus euh général vous avez
entendu ce qui a été dit la France dans
sa présence en Afrique n'a pas défendu
les intérêts africains comment vous
réagissez quand vous entendez
cela j'ai trouvé les propos du colonel
kit très très intéressant il a soulevé
des des choses des réalités euh qui nous
qui nous remonte peut-être un peu à la
figure aujourd'hui effectivement les les
missions des no bases français de la
présence militaire française c'est
d'abord la protection des intérêts
vitaux bien sûr don don les
ressortissants les intérêts économiques
qui sont qui sont assez minimes il faut
le pour ceux qui connaissent la partie
il faut le le reconnaître aujourd'hui et
puis enfin les intérêts de puissance et
c'est ça qui qui était extrêmement
important aujourd'hui la France qui se
fait une puissance moyenne à vocation
mondiale sans l'Afrique elle aura du mal
à assumer ça et donc je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le colonel le le la France
a besoin d'une relation particulière
avec l'Afrique et elle doit la soigner
et se faire comprendre du du du
continent africain et c'est peut-être ça
justement qui a qui a oui mais le
colonel a dit que la la France n'a pas
pris en considération les intérêts
africains qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
cela vous col
général j'y venais cher Monsieur j'y
venais en fait quand nous expliquons
aujourd'hui la présence militaire
française en Afrique on ne se focalise
que sur nos intérêts les intérêts que
nous défendons et la raison pour
laquelle sont là et et et jamais
quasiment nous n'expliquons euh quel
intérêts l'Afrique peut retirer de cette
présence militaire moi je me rappelle
avoir au début des années 2000 j'étais à
l'Élysée en charge des dossiers de
sécurité en Afrique et nous avons eu
exactement le même problème sur le la la
situation en Côte d'Ivoire en 2002 quand
nous sommes intervenus pour euh séparer
les les rebelles du Nord et et et les
gens du Sud et les et les forces
d'armées du Sud on a été construé
d'abord en Côte d'Ivoire on nous a
demandé ce qu'on ce
qu'on de quoi nous mélions-nous ensuite
nous avons été ça s'est répandu dans les
journaux de toutes les capitales
africaines et on était j'allis dire
incapable d'expliquer pourquoi et ben
quel était l'intérêt de la présence
militaire française pour l'Afrique pour
les Africains et c'est un dossier très
lourd que j'ai eu apportter donc l'idé
puisque j'étais en charge de la
situation sécuritaire en Afrique et et
pour lequel la réponse que nous avons
donné c'est que nous avons couplé notre
présence militaire française en Afrique
à la montée en puissance des forces
africaines en attente et on a donné très
clairement comme mission à chacune de
nos bases de se mettre à la disposition
des sous-régions africaine pour l'aider
aider à la montée en puissance de ce
qu'on appelle la Force Africaine en
Attente l'Union africaine ayant avec les
sous-régions décidé de faire monter en
puissance une force interafricaine au
niveau de chacune des région et donc la
base du Sénégal va se metter à la
disposition de la CDAO la base de
Djibouti à la miss la disposition
de de la de pardon la sous-région de
ligade oui pardon merci le Gabon à la à
la disposition de la CAC et la base de
la Réunion puisque nous n'avons pas de
présence historique en Afrique australe
la base de la réunion se mettait à la
disposition de la SADC et j'ai eu à
aller expliquer ce dispositif à l'Union
africaine et à chacune des sous-régions
et je peux vous dire que dans les mois
qui ont suivi tout s'est calmé parce que
nous avions répondu à l'interrogation
africaine pourquoi êtes-vous présent
aujourd'hui vous militaires français en
Afrique peut-être que cet effort là il
serait bon de le refaire aujourd'hui
pour que notre présence si nous la
maintenons soit acceptter merci
général
[Musique]
bien nous allons poursuivre euh notre
conversation alors il y a un paradoxe
les coups d'État en Afrique Mali Burkina
Faso Niger ça a été rappelé se sont
accompagnés d'un sentiment
anti-français alors que la franceafrique
il faut bien le reconnaître aujourd'hui
est en céphalogramme plat ou même
quasiment disparu est-ce que à votre
avis nagalé
Bakayoko est-ce que ce sentiment
anti-français était lié à la présence
des bases
militaires en tout cas il s'agit du
symbole avec le franc CFA qui est le
plus souvent brandi aujourd'hui pour
dénoncer une présence qui est perçue
comme beaucoup trop inrusive dans les
affaires régaliennes des États africains
mais il y a eu plusieurs éléments qui
ont amené à ce que je suis d'accord avec
le colonel il convient à mon avis
davantage de qualifier de sentiment de
rejet de la politique étrangère de la
France en Afrique plutôt que de
sentiments anti-français en tant que tel
parce que ce sont précisément tous ces
attributs perçus comme la survivance
d'un système qui a démontré son son
inefficacité qui sont remis en cause
aujourd'hui on a suffisamment parlé de
la lutte contre le terrorisme pourquoi
est-ce que il y a rejet aujourd'hui
parce qu'on estime dans les opinions
publiques africaines que la France
malgré les moyens dont elle affirmait
disposer c'est révélé tout à fait
incapable de contenir l'expansion des
insurrections djihadistes ou commettant
des des actes terroristes mais par
ailleurs on reproche aussi à la France
SA collusion avec un certain nombre de
régimes qui n'étaient que des
démocraties de façade voir son
indulgence envers des régimes militaires
pchiste comme le Tchad par exemple et sa
sévérité envers d'autres c'est son
double discours les doubles standards
qu'elle utilise qui sont remises en
cause enfin on lui reproche aussi la
façon dont formellement elle s'adresse
par le biais de ses plus hautes
autorités aux acteurs africains qui s'ag
agit des sociétés civiles ou des
autorités étatiques à travers un
discours qui apparaît comme beaucoup
trop moralisateur ou paternaliste c'est
à mon avis cela qui nourrit le sentiment
de rejet de la politique actuellement
menée par la France en Afrique merci
alors colonel quch je voudrais avoir
votre avis là-dessus les bases
militaires françaises ne sont plus là au
Mali au Burkina au Niger concernant la
mondialisation économique la France est
complètement distancée par des pays
comme le la Chine la la Russie la
Turquie et
cetera pourquoi persiste alors dans ce
cas-là un sentiment anti-français
puisque la France Afrique est plus là
les bases militaires sont plus
là on revoit ce qu'a été la la politique
française en Afrique
donc à mon avis c'est à l'Afrique à
refonder sa politique sans la France
France on peut pas demander à continuer
avec un pays avec lequel on a souhaité
rompre et des liens militaire et à
amoindrir les liens économiques pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a souhaité rompre ces liens
le général a parlé tout à l'heure de la
réorientation des missions des bases
françaises en Afrique dans le cadre de
la montée en puissance des forces en
attente mais mais désolé on doit noter
aujourd'hui qu'il y a une fa volonté de
de de de des Français de puissamment
équiper les armées africaines plus de 60
ans de formation les équipements
aujourd'hui dans les armées africaines
dirigés par la France ou bien formés par
la France ont encore des équipements
véust moi je peux vous dire que nous
sommes tous les pays africains nous
sommes profondément jaloux de tout ce
qui est donné à l'Ukraine donnez-nous le
tiers de ce qui a été donné à l'Ukraine
et nous allons combattre le terrorisme
notamment les moyens
aériens
donc si les les les relations sont
rompues les ce qu'ell restent les
cequell restent et puis cette cette
grosse arnaque du francfat mais on vit
pas en se faisant supppurer le passé
colonel non on on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas avancer sans tenir compte du passé
ce n'est pas une la rupture n'est pas
brutale encore que je vous ai dit que
c'est ce n'est pas un sentiment français
en tant que tel non c'est un sentiment
antipolitique française nos relations
avec les Français restent nos relations
avec les Français restent mais il
faudrait les réorienter dans l'intérêt
des africain aujourd'hui ce doit être du
win-win ce doit être du winwin ces bases
africaines dans leur conception initial
ne nous servent pas à grand-chose
puisqu'on vous l'a démontré tout à
l'heure nous ne voyons pas nos intérêts
dans la PR je vous pose la question et
elle va être posée à tous nos
intervenants est-ce que vous êtes
favorable au aujourd'hui à ce que la
France évacue toutes ses bases
militaires à savoir en Côte d'Ivoire au
Sénégal au Gabon à
Djibouti puisque la question est posée
dans l'intérêt
supérieur quand quand on regarde quand
on fait le bilan de cette de cette la
présence de ces forces militaires le le
Mali n'a pas recouvré l'intégralité de
son de son
territoire au au en RCA on a toujours
des conflits Inter communautaire donc le
résultat il est vraiment marginal dans
ces dans ces
conditions moi je pense que dans
l'intérêt supérieur de la France ces
bases doivent être retirées et c'est
déjà trop tard toutes ces
bases toutes ces bases encore que
l'Afrique n'est pas n'est pas un pays
l'Afrique n'est pas un pays comme vous
dites France Afrique Afrique France
l'Afrique n'est pas un pays l'Afrique
est un continent qui a plusieurs pays et
effectivement les bases n'existent pas
sur tous les États africains donc à la
fin ce sera géré au cas par cas en
fonction des intérêts de chaque pays
mais mon sentiment personnel ancien
militaire ayant combattu les
terrorisme dans certains points de
l'Afrique moi je pense que le bilan ne
nous permet pas aujourd'hui d'accepter
la PR des bases françaises si leurs
missions ne sont pas réorientées dans
l'intérêt des Africains comme l'a dit le
général tout à l' vous entendez Antoine
Glazer ce que dit le colonel il faut
évacuer toutes les bases militaires
est-ce que
c'est quel est votre point de vue mon
point de vue c'est qu'il faut déjà
comprendre pourquoi ces bases étaient là
ces bases elles étaient là dans une
période historique très particulière
donc que tout on a l'impression que tout
le monde a oublié ces 30 ans où
finalement même les propres alliés de la
France était très content que la France
soit au nom de la lutte contre l'Union
soviétique pendant toute cette période
de guerre froide en Afrique la France
assurait finalement pour l'Occident ass
servait assurit la sécurité contre
l'Union soviétique de 60 jusqu'en à la
chute du mur de Berlin 45 mais ça a
continué jusqu'à la chute du mur de
Berlin si on prend en compte cette
période historique qu'on appelle pour
faire court ce système intégré de la
France Affrique où la France non
seulement elle avait ses bases
militaires mais du point de vue
économique de la France elle avait le
pétrole elle avait l'uranium elle avait
les marchés à 50 60 % parce que ses
propres alliés comme l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne est devenu le premier
exportateur de l'Europe vers l'Afrique
donc je veux dire la France elle avait
l'armée elle avait ce système intégré
maintenir des bases permanentes en
Afrique pendant que la France a
continuer à faire le gendarme après
cette période c'est les autres qui
faisaient le business donc il faut un
certain moment donné en tenir compte la
France n'a pas vu l'Afrique se
mondialiser on parle toujours bien sûr
de la Russie de Wagner mais mais vous
avez les Turcs qui proposent des drones
vous avez les Américains qui sont pas
partis du Niger alors que la France
s'est fait virer du Niger vous voyez
bien que la France n'est pas seule et
nous on parle toujours de la
francearique la franceafrique c'est une
période historique mais maintenant c'est
terminé c'est c'est open bar pour tout
le monde on va rester quand même sur les
bases militaires général Clément bolet
vous avez entendu ce qu'a dit le colonel
quitch ce qu'a dit Antoine Glazer est-ce
que la France doit évacuer toutes ses
bases militaires en Afrique et je vous
poserai une question qui est corrélative
à ce point-là est-ce qu'on resterait
dans ce cas-là une grande puiss
même si c'est on nous considère
aujourd'hui comme une puissance moyenne
mais j'aimerais avoir votre avis très
clairement sur ces bases militaires
ououi mais je vais bien sûr vous le vous
le
donner je pense que aujourd'hui il y a
effectivement ce sentiment antifrançais
qui se focalise comme très bien dit
niagalé sur l'image du militaire parce
que parce que c'est le Bou émissaire
facile parce qu'il est très visible et
que notre dispositif est très très
visible les drapeaux de Français qui
dans les rues d' bjan ou voilà tout ça
est très visible et et et le problème
quand même qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui
c'est une chaque base militaire
française est un Nilo d'exaspération de
la rue africaine c'est ça qu'on vit
aujourd'hui je suis encore une fois
absolument d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
avec l'analyse d'ine lasazer c'est ces
temps ont vécu maintenant j'ai
l'impression que dans dans ce débat on
on on fait
pas soit on on maintient les bases soit
on les évacue mais il y a peut-être un
dispositif intermédiaire qui fait que
repenser repenser notre façon de gérer
les affaires
sécuritaires les dossiers sécuritaires
français en Afrique repenser la forme de
notre présence pourquoi pourquoi s'en
priver pourquoi ne pas le faire en en
corrélation avec nos nos partenaires
africains pour cette présence revisité
reformer je parlais tout à l'heure d'un
dispositif de coopération militaire
peut-être que c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
réorienter un un un engagement français
mais enfin pour répondre en tout cas euh
cl clairement à votre question moi je
pense que le le le l'heure des bases
françaises en Afrique a vécu est fini et
et qu'on et que maintenir une base
française en Afrique c'est se mettre en
en en c'est c'est créer un un un îo
desaspiration on le voit bien dans les
rues du Sénégal dans les rues de de
Dakar dans les rues de de d'Abidjan
regardez ce que pense l'opinion publique
lisez les journaux locaux il faudrait
pas que ça se termine comme au nigerre
voilà moi je crois que si on anticipe ça
si on comprend bien ça sur on analyse
bien ça et que si on réfléchit à
inscrire une un engagement sécuritaire
en relation penser en relation avec nos
partenaires africains et notamment en y
soulignant leur intérêt et tout ça
inscrit dans une nouvelle ENF une
nouvelle politique africaine de la
France avec sa dimension développement
avec sa dimension économique avec sa
dimension
sociale aurait tout son sens en tout cas
je suis farouchement opposé à ce que la
France rompe ses relations avec
l'Afrique on a on vous a entendu merci
général madame Aminata Traoré voulez
intervenir sur ce point et sur merci
d'ussi de nous donner votre point de vue
sur la présence ou la fin de ces bases
militaires en Afrique base militaire
française c'est mon tour oui c'est à
vous oui d'accord non je vis je voudrais
juste et et par rapport au sentiments
antifrançais rappeler que et les
sanctions et imposé au Mali par la CDAO
ont joué un rôle déterminant dans la
colère de la Ruch non seulement au Mali
dans différents pays et jusqu'au niveau
des diaspora et ça c'est extrêmement
important en raison de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la punition collective elle
est aujourd'hui infligée au peuple du
Niger au nom du retour à l'ordre
constitutionnel normal maintenant pour
ce qui est des bases militaires moi je
pense que il faut vraiment être à
l'écoute de ces toutes ces vous ne
pouvez pas vous imaginer les dynamiques
qui sont en cours ici comment les gens
sont sortis pourquoi les gens sont
sortis alors quand on pense que et la
guerre en tout cas l'intervention
militaire
n'a pas tenu ses promesses dans le cas
du Mali en tout cas et certainement
d'autres pays saéliens et qu'il fallait
que la France parte c'est c'est là qu'il
faut entendre je ne suis pas moi je ne
suis pas jaloux
des moyens militaires donnés à l'Ukraine
et ici je crois que ce qui convient le
mieux le plus aujourd'hui à une région
du monde comme l'Afrique c'est comme
l'Union africaine l'a dit mais sans
pouvoir faire quoi que ce soit faire
taire les armes tout comme on plaide
aujourd'hui pour le CC en Palestine il
faut faire taire les armes en Ukraine en
Palestine au Congo et au Sahel nous
avons cruellement besoin de ces moyens
la guerre ne profite qu' lob de
l'armement c'est la seule industrie qui
marche aujourd'hui qui crée des emplois
c'est le lieu par excellence du business
merci Madame merci Madame Aminata tra
alors
oui oui terminé alors parce qu'on a peu
de temps non je m'excuse non peut-être
que mes arguments ne plaisent pas mais
je veux juste dire que toutes ces
guerres sont les guerres de la
mondialisation prédatrice il faut faire
taire les armes merci on vous a alors
niagal Bakayoko je voudrais quand même
vous vous dire pour poser cette question
géostratégique bon que l'Afrique veuille
reprendre son destin en main on le
comprend qu'elle veuille le faire hors
d'une présence militaire
française ça ça semble même aujourd'hui
un avis favorable vous l'avez entendu le
général Clément baolet mais l'Afrique va
aussi vers d'autres pôles
géostratégiques elle des pays comme
comme l'Afrique du Sud l'Éthiopie ont
rejoint les briques où il y a la Chine
la Russie des pays comme l'Iran et
d'autres pays qui sont pas neutres dans
les conflits mondiaux et qui même les
attisent parce que l'Iran est impliqué
dans le terrorisme islamiste la Russie
est impliquée dans le désastre ukrainien
et on voit des pays africains rentrer
là-dedans comment vous vous voyez cette
Afrique au de demain hors une présence
française mais
euh sous
influence d'autres continents alors
plusieurs éléments alors l'Iran n'est
absolument pas impliqué dans le
terrorisme en Afrique hein quel que soit
le quel que soit la façon dont on prend
l'équation on peut parler éventuellement
des puissances telles et qui ne sont pas
Iran est impliqué dans le terrorisme à
travers les
R et si on parle de l'Afrique je veux
dire l'Arabie Saoudite ou le Qatar on on
on on certainement plus d'influence sur
l'islamisationricain sont rentrés dans
le groupe des bricks où l'Iran est
rentré en prés mais mais c'était
simplement pour pour pour pour
mentionner ce point là ce qui est très
important c'est que pour moi ce qui se
produit d'historique comme le dit
Antoine Glazer aujourd'hui et cette
volonté des États africains de
diversifier leur partenariats et de
maximiser leurs intérêts et à mon sens
cela n'exclut absolument pas la France à
terme alors aujourd'hui on est dans une
période de crispation intense mais je
pense que d'ici quelques années 4 ou 5
ans toutô plus il y aura cohabitation de
différents partenaires vous parler de la
Russie il est quand même très
intéressant si on prend le cas de la
Libye de voir que la Russie à travers
Wagner soulignons-le soutenait le même
camp à savoir celui du maréchal aftar
que la France donc ce type de
partenariat très opportuniste de la part
des États africains qui renvoie tout
simplement à la politique à la réelle
politique de toute état dans le monde
fait que à mon avis des partenaires de
nature très différentes vont cohabiter
les uns à côté des autres dans les
coopérations notamment militaires qui
vont se mettre en place dans les années
à venir entre le continent africain et
différentes zones géographiques de par
le monde oui Antoine gazer vous part
cette vision
géopacifique enfin pas géopacifique
nagalé elle a jamais
ditacifique elle dit simplement et je
suis complètement d'accord avec elle ça
veut dire les Africains ils prennent en
compte ce que nous on n pas pris en
compte on a continué à croire qu'on
était chez nous dans le 13 anciennes
colonies c'est-à-dire les Africains ils
prennent en compte toutes les
opportunités qui s'offrent à eux mais
vous avez raison c'est vrai qu'il y a
une répartition des tâches en Afrique
entre les Chinois qui font vraiment euh
qui sont le qui font le business les
Russes qui font aussi une partie de la
sécurité mais c'est de la faute de la
France qui s'est retiré des pays comme
le centra-afrique à un moment donné qui
a laissé arriver Wagner qui a abandonné
le terrain sont les Russes qu' ont fait
les négociations avec les rebelles
centra-fricains et vous avez et vous
avez raison de parler on parle on a
parlé beaucoup géopolitique mais vous
avez raison de parler de géoéconomie
parce qu'à mon avis maintenant l'Afrique
va redevenir totalement géo stratégique
sur le plan des matières premières des
pays comme la RDC le sont déjà pour le
tental et autres mais vous avez le
lithium je sais que les Américains en
centraafrique sont en train de regarder
des gisements de terr rares donc on est
dans une période historique il faut que
la France elle elle elle prenne en
compte la mondialisation de l'Afrique
c'est pour ça que c'est c'est quelque
chose qui c'est c'est vraiment une
question historique et ce boomerang que
se prend la France sur les sentiments
anti-français et comme vous vous-même
vous dites mais je comprends pas on a
plusintérêt et il y a les sentiments
antifrançais mais et C espèce de retour
de retour du de l'impensée comme on dit
bien ben écoutez on va s'arrêter là il y
a beaucoup de questions qu'on pourrait
poser on aurait pu continuer mais on
fera une prochaine émission sur ce
sujet-l je voudrais vous remercier mais
avant de vous remercier je voudrais vous
citer une brève bibliographie alors
Aminata Traoré vous avez publier l'ETO
ou l'Afrique dans un monde sans
frontières on a eu l'occasion d'en
parler on a on a vraiment très peu de
temps en deux
mots qu'est-ce que vous vouliez dire
dans cette Afrique dans un monde sans
frontière mais vraiment deux mots parce
qu'on a très peu de temps
non je voulais juste dire que euh le
monde est en train de changer et que on
a on nous a parlé de monde sans
frontières mais en réalité il n'y a que
des
murs bien B voilà une définition Antoine
Glazer vous avez publié parmi vos
nombreux ouvrages sur l'Afrique arrogant
comme un français en Afrique donc vous
dénoncez cette arrogance oui c'est moi
ce qui m'a surpris en tant que
journaliste hein je suis pas expert ni
rien ce qui m'a surpris c'est comment la
France a exporté sur tout un continent
toute sa sa science son savoir-faire sa
constitution en dehors de sa langue et à
contrôler complètement les états un ce
nombre de pays et n'a pas appris de
l'Afrique je pense que là il faut
changer le logiciel il faut s'intéresser
à l'Afrique intéressé aux Africains moi
ce qui m'était intéressé c'est les
systèmes de parenté en Afrique ça veut
dire inverser totalement le logiciel
merci Antoine alors niagaleé Bagayoko
c'est pas un livre mais vous avez publié
une étude sur le multilatéralisme
sécuritaire africain à l'épreuve de la
crise sahélienne oui parce que il n'y a
pas que la France qui est rejetée sur le
continent africain il n'y a pas que les
autres partenaires internationaux comme
les Nations Unies il y a aussi une très
forte remise en cause des acteurs
multilatéraux comme l'Union africaine
comme la CDEAO comme la CEAC qui ont
elles aussi démonrer leur incapacité à
faire face à la crise sécuritaire
actuelle donc la remise en cause est
globale et ne concerne pas que la France
aujourd'hui alors il me reste à vous
remercier merci mesdames merci messieurs
d'avoir participé à cette brillante
conversation et prospective puisque vous
avez des choses ont été mises
aujourd'hui
je voudrais remercier l'équipe de LCP
qui a permis donc la réalisation de
cette émission et avant de nous quitté
je vous rappelle cette pensée de
Jean-Marie Beauquel un ancien ministre
français qui a été touché
personnellement puisqu'il a perdu un
fils dans les combats en Afrique les
coups d'État en Afrique n'améliore en
rien la situation des pays concernés au
contraire
[Musique]